on this Monday night a Relentless fight
against an unrelenting Wildfire the
people defying orders to leave staying
to defend the town of Hay River we're
doing our best we're doing our best plus
the Vicious Cycle of carbon emissions
wildfires and the warming planet
deepening threat what cyber criminals
are expected to Target in Canada over
the next two years the ballooning cost
of going back to school it is getting
more challenging how some parents are
maximizing budgets and writing a
decades-old wrong today was probably one
of the most Happy Days In My Life The
Return of a stolen totem pole to a BC
First Nation
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we are
watching an out of control Wildfire
looming over the town of Hay River
tonight the mayor says it is on the
town's doorstep and firefighters in the
Northwest Territories are doing all they
can to hold it back the weather is not
on their side temperatures are expected
to soar to 35 degrees this week no rain
is forecast and the smoke is making it
difficult for aerial Crews to battle the
Flames most people in town have fled
those who have stayed put are now on the
front line Mike Armstrong has our top
story tonight
foreign
the hay River fire is at some spots
barely a kilometer and a half from the
center of town this video was shot
Monday by Aaron Campbell battle every
day it seems like we win one fight lose
another fight win another fight move on
to the next fight
Campbell's children evacuated to Alberta
he and his wife stayed to help it's been
mostly 14-hour days one after another
protecting the town where he was born
and raised with welcome support we're
getting people from BC from Fort Nelson
they come up and help got guys from
Ontario that are here right now today we
had the local boys from Fort Simpson
come in there and they just bashed it it
was awesome heavy heavy smoke
about a hundred people have ignored the
evacuation order to leave the woman who
shot this video is doing daily rounds
checking on people's homes and feeding
pets everything looks calm quiet and
Smoky as hell now that smoke is keeping
helicopters out of the fight there were
Windows over the weekend where they were
able to fly and Monday's winds haven't
been as strong that's helped but
visibility is limited
see where you're going if you can't see
where your targets are that's an
unacceptable risk to human life there
there are about 200 people working to
fight the fire but the mayor says
they're trying to put more boots on the
ground finding them has been the
challenge we're looking for trained
people you can't just bring anybody in
and put them in the line of fire and
hope to keep them safe the mayor says
right now the focus is still on the fire
itself some people who are needed for
essential work are being allowed to
return home but lifting the evacuation
order isn't in the short term there are
fires along the highway you know so
that's going to be people are going to
have to have patience
the forecast for the coming days is a
mixed bag winds will be from the north
and that will help there isn't any
substantial rain expected for several
days
Mike Armstrong Global News
the wildfires are causing huge upheaval
and uncertainty the territorial
government has decided to delay its
October election because of them voters
will now go to the polls six weeks later
on November 14th the Northwest
Territories has smashed the 2014 record
for wildfires as measured by heat output
and the toxic emissions from smoke are
having a major impact on the environment
this year wildfires in the territory
have emitted 107 megatons of carbon into
the air and with that comes in increased
risk for wildfires to release even more
carbon into the atmosphere as Eric
Sorensen reports there's an urgency to
better understand its effects
Canada's boreal forest is our Ally in
fighting climate change a vast carbon
sink that absorbs greenhouse gas
emissions but when trees burn carbon is
released as Canada and Northern
latitudes warm twice as fast as the rest
of the planet a vicious cycle is being
triggered carbon emissions are warming
the planet which is drying the forests
creating more fuel for wildfires and
releasing even more carbon stored in
those trees if we put more CO2 in the
atmosphere that'll cause more of the
drought which cause more of the fires so
we end up with what's called a positive
feedback loop but it's by no means
positive it's actually very negative for
climate the world's boreal forests are
only in the north Russia and Canada have
by far the most this country alone has
28 percent of the world's Boreal Zone
550 million hectares the record for
carbon from Canadian wildfires was set
in 2014 138 megatons this year 377
megatons of carbon almost three times
the previous record what's remarkable is
the number of intense fire regions this
year wildfires began in May primarily in
Alberta Quebec saw huge fires in June
that blanketed Eastern Canada and the
U.S in Smoke in July intense fires
burned in parts of BC by early August
fires were burning in the high Arctic
down towards Yellowknife and this week
in the Northwest Territories south of
great Slave Lake
70 percent of Canada's indigenous
communities are in forested regions and
they are most at risk for pollutants
from wildfires there's a wide range of
impacts on the carbon side but also the
air pollution side particular matter
volatile organic compounds uh Benzene
toluene really unpleasant things that
have direct consequences for human
health particulates from smoke will also
speed the melting of Arctic Ice the
cascading effects of wildfires in our
forests are apt to accelerate the
consequences of climate change we count
on forests to convert our CO2 to the
oxygen that we breathe and as we lose
more and more of it we're going to have
less and less of that process the Boreal
Forester very important sink for CO2
Greg Evans believes as bad as it is this
year the records being set for wildfires
and carbon emissions will likely be
broken in future years Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto
in BC some positive signs the Wildfire
situation is improving around Kelowna
though it's destroyed many homes and is
still out of control firefighters have
now pushed back the McDougall Creek Fire
into the hills Beyond residential areas
that's allowed thousands of evacuees to
return home but with unusually warm
temperatures across the province BC's
record Wildfire season is not over
it has been heartening to watch many
people return home in recent days
however many communities still remain on
alert and Order and many wildfires
remain highly active
more Wildfire resources are being sent
to the northern half of BC because of
the unseasonably high temperatures there
more than 370 active wildfires are
burning across the province more than
150 of them are out of control and about
8 000 people are still under evacuation
orders
in Quebec police have now launched a
criminal investigation into a fire that
killed a number of people in a building
in Old Montreal the night of the fire
there were 22 people in the Heritage
building some of them staying in illegal
Airbnb rentals six escaped unharmed nine
were injured and seven died Montreal
police say they found evidence
suggesting the fire was deliberately set
our investigators have identified an
area where the fire started and I can
can confirm that traces of accelerant
were found which may help explain the
speed at which the blaze spread combined
with the building's Heritage structure
police are not disclosing any more about
the investigation at this point victims
families have been notified the fire in
March prompted Quebec to introduce new
legislation regulating short-term
rentals the building's owners also face
scrutiny over multiple fire code
violations flagged by inspectors over
the years
it is hurricane season in the Atlantic
and a storm named Franklin has rapidly
intensified Franklin is now a category 4
hurricane it is packing sustained winds
of about 230 kilometers an hour the
storm is expected to strengthen as
attracts just west of Bermuda by
Wednesday its impact though is already
being felt in the U.S the National
Hurricane Center warns life-threatening
Surf and rip currents are occurring
along the U.S east coast
some ominous signs of what's coming
along Florida's Gulf Coast where people
are being warned to brace for impact
tropical storm Adalia which started over
the Gulf of Mexico is now projected to
be a category 3 hurricane when it hits
Florida on Tuesday life-threatening
Storm surges up to three meters higher
forecast along with Winds of up to 160
kilometers an hour evacuations are
already underway in coastal communities
and the American president has approved
an emergency declaration for Florida
authorizing Federal Disaster Assistance
a trial date has been set for former U.S
president Donald Trump's election
interference case it will begin on March
4th 2024 in the middle of the Republican
Presidential primaries and the day
before super Tuesday special counsel
Jack Smith's team wanted the trial to
start in January of 2024. Trump's
lawyers argued it should be pushed until
April 2026 the federal judge overseeing
the case said neither of those dates was
acceptable last week Trump was booked on
separate criminal charges in Georgia and
is expected to enter a plea on those in
early September
back in this country a new federal
report warns ransomware attacks are now
the most disruptive form of Cyber attack
on Canadians and it paints a picture of
what links countries such as Russia and
Iran will go to and what they are
targeting is Mackenzie gray reports it
also highlights the potential digital
damage that could hit Canada's
infrastructure
after more than 18 months of Vladimir
Putin's war in Ukraine Moscow was opened
up a second front in cyberspace as long
as they don't Target Russian interest or
Russian citizens uh they are turning a
blind eye to their activity the Canadian
Center for cyber security warning the
Kremlin will allow cyber criminals to
operate with near impunity and extorting
Canadian organizations is fair game
pointing to ransomware attacks against
sick kids hospital in Toronto and other
major Canadian businesses the Russian
government is happy when we're dealing
with these sorts of problems and not
focusing on addressing the threat that
it's posing in the war in Ukraine those
attacks officially costing the Canadian
economy 530 million dollars annually but
with limited reporting the true cost is
considerably higher we assess that only
uh five to ten percent of victims
actually report to to law enforcement
and the online strikes are expected to
increase over the next two years with
the Cyber Center projecting criminals
will focus on high value targets like
electrical grids pipelines and airports
as long as those cyber criminals
continue to make money we suspect that
that will be an active uh sort of an
active targeting of Canadian and
Canadian business money also being
scammed off individual Canadians through
less sophisticated means criminals
impersonating organizations like the CRA
and Canada post as well as businesses
like Amazon ups and Netflix in a bid to
steal valuable personal and financial
information through phishing scams once
you click on it and your information is
out there in cyberspace putting the
toothpaste back in the tube is just not
possible one country missing from the
report China the head of the security
Center saying Beijing focuses its
activities on Steely intellectual
property Donna not on cybercrup
okay Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank you
28 handguns are off Toronto streets
thanks to a tip-off from hotel
housekeeping staff the handguns were
seized after cleaning staff at a North
York Hotel found three firearms on
August 21st and contacted police who
sealed the room and seized the weapons
officers executed a search warrant the
same day and discovered 25 additional
guns in the same hotel room
these guns were 100 destined for our
streets in Toronto and as a result of
this seizure they could not be used to
take someone else's life and severely
injure in Maine people
a 30-year-old Ottawa man faces 136
charges including possession of
prohibited devices and possession of a
gun with an altered serial number police
say a portion of the 28 Firearms seized
which includes 20 Glock pistols have
been traced back to the southern U.S
this year 382 illegal Firearms have been
seized in Toronto 1300 across Ontario
a lot of parents celebrate this time of
year this year though many are feeling
the squeeze with back-to-school budgets
how they're coping coming up plus caught
on camera the terrifying moment a
helicopter plunges from the sky
[Music]
somehow the summer has whipped by and
back to school is fast approaching
students in some provinces are already
back including these kids in Montreal
others head back to class next week it
is a busy sometimes stressful time for
many families and this year the rising
cost of living is adding to the strain
Taria Israel looks at what some parents
and kids are doing to keep costs down
at a time of stubborn inflation some
families are cutting back on back to
school shopping as a family we try to
reuse our backpacks and lunch bags
Canadians are scouring the aisles for
deals we were able to find some pretty
reasonably priced shoes actually
yesterday but uh
it is getting more challenging she's not
excited to go back to school
parents are not excited either when it
comes to the rising cost of raising
children the prices are of our weekly
spending is has gone up a significant
amount I mean snacks snacks are really
expensive now
snacks school supplies clothing it all
adds up while buying power is down if
you look at sort of pre-covered costs
for back to school versus now there's
going to be significant increases in
price Canadian parents plan to spend an
average of 524 dollars on back to school
shopping while a quarter of them say
they'll shell out less this year
compared to last because of inflation
business analysts say higher gas prices
are driving up retail prices and forcing
consumers to cut back
this secondhand store in Ottawa is
seeing a record number of first-time
customers six dollars I'd pay at least
35 bucks for this if I go to another
store owner Julie Gautier says more
families are coming through her doors
because they can't afford to buy brand
new they'd need to cut because
everything's gotten more expensive and
they're realizing that kids grow out of
things so fast they're also dropping off
more of their own hand-me-downs a lot of
people say that they're coming to sell
to us because they need gas or they need
you know food the retail Council of
Canada says more than two-thirds of
Canadians will go back to school
shopping this year and most of their
money will go to the big box stores they
end up taking more than 60 percent of
the profits
Global News Ottawa
still ahead prosecutors open an
investigation into Spain's soccer
Federation president over that World Cup
kiss
[Music]
this horrifying scene played out near
Fort Lauderdale Florida Today the
medical rescue helicopter caught fire in
Flight it crashed through the roof of an
apartment building two people were
killed one on board that helicopter one
on the ground four other people were
injured
Ukraine claims it has liberated a
strategic Village in the Southeast
Ukraine's defense Ministry posted this
video today after a week of grinding
combat soldiers raised the Ukrainian
flag in the settlement despite
resistance from Russian troops Russia is
denying the advance if true it could
help boost Ukrainian morale and open a
path towards the Sea of azov
hundreds of thousands of air Travelers
are facing delays across the UK and
Beyond after a technical issue shut down
Britain's air traffic control system
forcing it to revert to a manual system
more than 500 flights were canceled
thousands more delayed disrupting plans
for people during the August bank
holiday one of the busiest travel days
of the year the problem has been fixed
but it's going to take a few days for
Airlines to deal with all that disrupted
travel prosecutors in Spain have opened
a preliminary investigation into the
conduct of the country's top soccer
official after he forcibly kissed a
player on the lips as well as Spanish
soccer Federation has called on Luis
rubialis to resign immediately saying
the unacceptable Behavior has caused
Great damage to the image of Spanish
soccer on Saturday FIFA suspended him
for three months it's all sparked a
national debate about sexism sexual
aggression and abuse of power not only
because he grabbed and kissed the star
player Jenny hermoso on the lips after
Spain's win at the World Cup but because
of his Defiance afterward he claims what
he did was consensual hermoso says she
did not consent and feels she was a
victim of aggression
the Spanish holiday island of Majorca
was battered by torrential rain flooding
and wind gusts reaching a hundred
kilometers an hour the force of that
storm was so powerful on Sunday a cruise
ship Broke Free from its Moorings and
crashed into a fuel tanker then onto the
Rocks was a tense time for hundreds of
passengers on board the cruise ship
company says a small number of people
were injured the ship's structure they
say was not compromised
returning home next from Scotland back
to its people the story of a stolen
totem pole
for nearly a century a totem pole it was
carved on Canada's West Coast has sat in
a museum in Scotland members of the
niska first nation in BC say it was sent
there without consent in effect stolen
from the people who created it and for
whom it has the most meaning today a
niska delegation was in Edinburgh to
Mark the beginning of the Towering totem
Pole's journey home to a place where
generations of niska people have never
seen it Redmond Shannon reports
the first steps in a process almost a
century in the making for niska First
Nation Chief simulge Nish Joel it is a
moment of deep importance to his family
the beginning of the journey home for
the niche Joel Memorial totem pole from
its current location in the national
museum of Scotland today was probably
one of the most
Happy Days in my life because I I'm
really really emotional right now and I
and I could feel
my
ancestral
grandmother
the 11-meter pole was carved in the
1860s and depicts a warrior destined to
be Chief who was killed in battle with a
neighboring Nation Canadian
Anthropologist Marius Barbeau bolted in
1929 but niska Nation members say no one
would have had the right to sell
something so sacred when a pool is
carved just right before it's to be
raised there is a ceremony formed and
the Carver breathes life back into that
pole and so from that point forward once
it's raised we consider it to be a
living being and that it has its own
spirit so each one represents a sort of
constitutional chapter about the niska
peoples and our relationship to the
lands that we belong rather than a
repatriation the niska called this a
rematriation in line with their
matrilineal society moving it to the
British Columbia First Nation will be a
huge operation in recent years museums
around the world have been returning
items taken from colonized peoples this
the first totem to leave the UK it's a
huge challenge to museums and
governments right across the world to
confront the issue of cultural artifacts
and the circumstances in which they made
their way to Europe North America or
wherever else
Niche Joel says this return Isn't just
for his family and Community but for the
generations to come he'll be there for
them for years back it's it's really
an awesome feeling
The Towering totem is scheduled to
arrive at the niska Museum in late
September Redmond Shannon Global News
London
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
candidate is the Fabian Trestle bridge
near Fabian Alberta thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]
thank you